hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
and welcome to this video where I'll be
uh sort of continuing on the thread of
talking about orderflow imbalances you
know and imbalance occurs um in the
two-way auction between the volume
traded on the bid and the volume traded
on the offer right if um the volume
traded on the offer is more than 4 to
one versus what is traded against the
bid you'd consider that a buy and and
balance if the aggressive selling into
the bid is more than you know four to
one versus the aggressive buying from
the offer you consider that a selling
imbalance and you know what what's
unique about imbalances is you know it's
related to volume okay and you know
often times we we look at volume um as
you know strict numbers but when you're
looking at imbalances most Traders
actually look at it in a percentage and
you know that generally is not much of a
a problem but sometimes you know I have
what I call weak imbalances where it's
you know if you're using ratio of 4:1
and you have a volume of one against
eight yeah technically that's an
imbalance but uh you know do you
consider that uh a legitimate strong
imbalance and that's why sometimes you
know on imbalances I like to use a
minimum volume of say 10 in the
imbalance to consider that uh you know a
realistic imbalance and in most markets
that are liquid you know things like uh
you know es you know even Mees um
obviously the interest rates you know
volume like that is not an issue but
sometimes you know you're going to go
into say thinner markets you know for
example let me uh I'll just pull up
really quick here the euro currency
right the Euro FX just to give you an
example of what I'm talking about uh
let's you know find one here you know
two against 12 okay you know I I'd much
rather have you know one against 45 one
against 62 as opposed to um you know
three against
14 smaller numbers and you know
fortunately most software
allows you to filter those smaller
imbalances out so you're not looking at
you know an imbalance of say seven
against zero technically that's that's
an imbalance right seven traded on the
bid zero traded on the offer that's more
than 4 to one
but you you don't want to be sort of
looking at imbalances unless they have
some significance I like to use a
minimum of 10 and for most markets I I
think that's uh fine but again you know
when you're in thicker markets like
bonds interest
rates um you know liquidity and traded
volume is not going to be uh that big an
issue now let's just go back here to e
minis because what I want to talk about
is a tool that's on the orderflows
trader called imbalance reload okay now
you know there's different ways to look
at imbalances and you know I've talked
about stacked imbalances I talked about
that importance obviously it's a major
part of order flow right that's
something since um even before I started
using orderflow people were were mainly
keyed in on stack and balances it's
always been a major uh a major part of
my trading and a lot of orderflows
Traders uh trading plan um you know then
I had talked about also the importance
of stacked imbalances right where you
have or not stacked imbalan rather
refuse let me rephrase that um multiple
imbalances so just you know really quick
I'll just show you right
here and what that is multiple
imbalances is bars with three or more
imbalances in the bar like you have it
right here it actually comes in ahead of
where the Stacked imbalance comes in
okay so it's giving you a little bit of
a heads up prior to you know the buying
that's coming in here in the Stacked
imbalance and often times what happens
with stacked imbalance is and and why
it's important is because a stacked
imbalance is sort of a burst one order
big order going through the market and
what I found with multiple imbalances
it's you know sort
of um it's a big order but it's being
chopped up into smaller pieces and it's
the person is not really trying to show
their atttention to the market it's
buying some let's the market breathe buy
some more Let the market breathe buy
some more Let the market breathe as
opposed to someone just coming hey buy
me 200 S&P is at the market well you
know because you know 200 is not going
to move the market more than probably
two or three uh ticks but what I want to
talk about today
is another uh interesting Nuance in the
order flow it's what I call an imbalance
reload okay
so we have it on our uh order flows
Trader software imbalance reload and
it's going to be until tested Let's uh
I'm just going to turn off um to turn
off the Stacked imbalance because I
don't want you guys getting confused
over things so turn off stacked in
Balance I'm going to turn off the
multiple imbalance value right here okay
and it's just going to show the
imbalance reload okay because you know
it's it's important when you're looking
at imbalances normally we look at it
vertically right up and down in a
bar right like for example you know
stacked imbalance one two three stacked
on top of each other right multiple
imbalances one then spread out another
one and another one
now an imbalanced reload load right what
that is it's imbalances that are spread
out over two
bars buying imbalances right it's two
green candles so you're going to be
looking at the buying imbalances it's
two red candles you're going to be
looking at the selling IM balances and
you know honestly in a market that's
going sideways like we're seeing here
right this was uh just a little bit
earlier today before that big runup you
know we're in a range between 82 and a
half and you know 89 more or less and
you're seeing you know imbalance reload
imbalance reload okay you're in a
sideways
activity any sort of Clue the Market's
going to give you in sideways activity
is going to be hard to act on because
you don't know if this Market's really
breaking out or not not until you start
breaking out then you start seeing the
imbalances come in but what the
importance of an imbalance reload
is just go back here in time a little
bit when you get that imbalance
reload as the market starts breaking
down or breaking up and really what it
is now these are minute bars okay so you
can see imbalance reload here sustained
selling aggressive selling over one two
bars that's causing imbalances one two
bars it's causing imbalances here you
have an imbalance reload a bullish one
one bar two bar right it's coming in at
the same level so what's happening if
you understand how execution alos work
right there's there's a there's a bunch
of different execution out go and you
know one of the basic ones and there's a
lot of offshoots of this is is the time
slicer okay and you know what you do as
a you know as institutional Traders you
have your order buy me you know x amount
of whatever you're trading you Minis and
you know slice it up over time and then
it's it does like even smaller slices so
what you're seeing is you know a burst
of buying here let the market pull back
another burst burst of buying coming in
here just as here a burst of selling a
burst of selling now this one's coming
in again in an area we're starting to go
sideways now we're starting to break
down and you've got that imbalance
reload just as here we're starting to
break out all right your high was uh
right here before now you got that
aggressive buying it pulls back more
aggressive buying right I I like to
use um I like to draw out the imbalance
reload with like a Zone if it's bullish
like this or bearish like this cuz it
gives me a good visual quickly right
away that's telling me if I know that
we're starting to draw this out this
zone out that this
Market is starting to break out right
just as here well I'm not convinced yet
that this Market's starting to break
down because we're trading right around
it but if we're running away from that
the bullish one or running away from the
bearish one to me that that's going to
give me a a good area that could be
thinking of getting short right you see
even here we sort of come right back up
to that area before we sell off some
more um you know find another example
here you got one two you actually got
two in here but again all you got to do
is spend a little time look to the left
of your chart is this an area that we're
trading in or is it an area we're
breaking down to or breaking out of
rather you know this one start breaking
out it came right back to the tick here
traded even here sort of came right back
up to it again trading what are we doing
to the left right are we going sideways
and again you know one of the key points
of being a successful Trader is
understanding what kind of Market
condition we're in right are we in a
sideways Market because if we're in a
sideways Market no matter what you do is
it's not going to be very effective
right no matter what you're trading
unless your trading plan is you know
range trading right buy the low of the
range sell the high of the range me
personally I think it's more fruitful to
you know I would have taken this trade
but just go sideways on me after you're
getting in this one yeah I would have
loved to have taken it but it traded
right back up there in the next bar but
when you get down in here you know this
one sideways okay so there's three
potential trades
that you know just couldn't get any
movement on it then you hit this one
this is a nice trade here followed by a
beautiful trade right here s like Donald
Trump oh that's the best you know most
beautiful trade where it really comes
right back up to that level before you
got that big
selloff all right and again you know
take it in
context up here 56 11 a half you get
your imbalance reload where the market
runs away then you get down here you got
another imbalance reload at 78 and 3/4
okay or 79 rather
well it's a 30o move you know do do you
still want to be taking an additional
short after 30 the market sells off 30
points probably not um you know
but that's that's my Logic on there but
again just look to the left when you see
an imbalance reload is it coming in an
area you've been trading sideways okay
and if it has are we breaking out or
breaking down okay and the clue is going
to get often times going to come in in
the bar afterwards
all right so again look to the left are
we trading sideways look to the right
are we starting to move away from it or
not right that's going to give you an
opportunity to catch a trade like this
or even halfway decent trade like this
one so that is uh imbalance reload okay
and you know a question I get often
is you know hey Mike I traded an hourly
chart or a 4H hour chart you know what's
some of the tools that I could use for
um analyzing the order flow well to be
honest right if you're training a 4-Hour
chart you probably don't need to use
order flow just follow price because I
mean 4 hours
is you know half a trading day right the
the US
hours and you know something that you're
seeing happening in the order
flow that happens you know 15 minutes
into your your 4our chart is probably
not going to um last for three hours the
next three and a half hours you so for
example like five minutes I I do look at
five minute charts I'll just pull it up
here really quick and and show you what
I mean is you know when you're looking
at things like imbalance reloads right
you don't get a whole heck of a lot of
them like here's one here's a bearish
one on a f minute chart simply because
you got five minutes to rotate around
where that imbalance was okay so that's
why you know there there's certain parts
of order flow that aren't going to be as
effective on on a longer term chart I
can't really consider five minutes a
longer term chart but you get the point
that I'm trying to make now if I was
looking at a a FIV minute chart there's
other things I would focus on that's
more um volume related as opposed to
more related in the two-way auction you
can see in the night well not night
session but 600 in the morning There's 7
in the morning there's one there you get
some in the in the evening session but
obviously the evening session is a lot
slower um that's 6:00 but you see the
day before again you had one up here but
there's just a lot of time you know if
you're on a FIV minute chart for it to
sort of come in and fill that's why you
don't see necessarily a whole heck of a
lot of imbalances on a five- minute
chart and again you know you want to
take advantage of things like imbalances
Market imbalances as quickly as you can
so you know to sort of to sum up if
you're on a a longer term chart again I
hate to use that term longer term chart
to I'm talking about a 5 minute chart
but you understand what I'm saying
is
just bear in mind you probably want to
look at other things in the order flow
things that are volume related okay so
anyway I'll probably talk about that in
a different video so again I hopefully
you found this uh this video useful and
you know sort of open your eyes a little
bit into other different ways of looking
at
imbalances in the order flow right so
thanks everyone and I'll see you guys on
the next video